I don't know man yes that was Maisie  Williams epic a response to ET about her  character Aria ever getting a love  interest on Game of Thrones which is  back for season six colleges for your  legacy I'm excited for other people to  be able to watch this season without  having any spoilers like I do I'm kind  of jealous he'll just be but no it's an  incredible incredible episode and people  have a lot to look forward to we caught  up with the 19 year old star at the  premiere of her new movie devil and the  deep blue sea which co-stars Jason  Sudeikis he's got very dark themes for  his character throughout and so a lot of  days on set he was you know in the zone  and like I was kind of respectful of  that but it says we've sorry impressed  he is hilarious  and of course is hilarious but it's been  really nice to see some of that like in  full swing now